I mean come on you're here at comic-con
and you're in this show so many fans are
excited for and then we have the og of
oh jeez actually I'm sorry but I think
there must have been some
misunderstanding we're the new cast of
games from the game and all Game of
Thrones in space how does how does
explain what makes Picard get back in
the mix after he's retired because
retirement is not what he was looking
for not what he wanted it was an
impulsive act that put him in this
situation and he is regretted it and
lived with a certain amount of guilt
about it for many years and that's where
we pick up the show and from there we go
and you do have a couple of friends with
you who returned and which is cool but
first of all is being a disassemble is
that what we see well I don't think
that's what you see exactly you see by
the trailer we see something in a drawer
you're fooling yourself we see something
like that yes I sure you see you're the
only one who saw them are you okay yeah
you're back yeah but you're it's a nice
it I am but you'll have to I can't tell
you right now you're not here are you
no that's the garbage
up what if the reception billing here at
comic-con have you had a chance of
Washington walk the floor and I'm
excited if I walk the floor
I think the mob that would ensue yeah I
mean when we showed the trailer the the
you know the room filled with so much
love so much support so much excitement
and anticipation and it just made our at
least for me feel like all the work
we've done is really um it's gonna be so
well received you could see the room we
didn't walk before we could see that
yeah and it was like what a beautiful
responsibility we have to bring this
back to something that's been so long
awaited the fact that we get to do that
and see their reaction in front of us is
so special and with with our fans you
guys they're just starting to get on our
ship right they'll follow you to every
job Anthony would ever do and you will
have loyal fans for the rest of your
life my canyon what what you have to
understand is the power of this show I
will never forget into the second season
of TNG when Whoopi Goldberg joined us
and she just won an Academy Award and I
said why why would you like want to do a
syndicated science-fiction show when
you're in a war I kept me Award winner
and she told me this is a story about
her childhood and how she watched the
original series the very first one and
she would see the character of her there
and she said I told myself well one of
us made it I found that so potent that
remarkable is and it in a multitude of
different ways that's what Star Trek in
all of its different life forms has
meant to millions of people
GameChanger as far as a program that
really is inclusive and you turn on the
TV and you're like wow these are the
real stories told in a fictional way
that helped change the world yes here's
a news we don't want to know could there
be a discovery crossover crossover okay
and also what will we see from your rag
as they're described your ragtag crew
tell you about this ragtag crew it was
bodily sympathy well you're gonna see
first why I'd like to just this is so
true what you said about will be and
it's so wonderful that we have we're
continuing on being inclusive and
diverse and you know you know look at
this you know it's it's um it wasn't
powerful for me as well and I was young
and seeing myself represented and there
was not that many
I love that that's this franchise this
this iconic you know world is really you
know grabs that and wants to make sure
that that is clear and that's we're all
here my character is a little broken a
little got some issues she is part of in
an unrelated way for cards past
so um that's what I can say about that
and then I'll just pass it off to one of
my other members it's just about the
crew in on Monday we're shooting a scene
in which Riker who is in the series I
don't think I'm he said - he says to me
so you're your new crew what are they
like and I do actually describe them as
motley we've got please you know you
talk about the legacy of Star Trek but
for the new folks would it mean to book
something like this when you're you're
like because people never be you are
something this is something that goes on
forever I think regardless of that it's
a really exciting story and so all of
that an extra on top oh yeah you know -
if what's brilliant about acting is that
you get to be different people and
experience different histories you got
to time travel this is the this is the
first time I've gotten to the future
time travel is as an actor and it's
great it feels like how is the future
it's good man it looks amazing and you
come out of work and you rap and you're
going to drive back in LA and you're
like I'm back in the contemporary scene
well and I've been spending my day in
the future so really fascinating amazing
kind of stories and Karen
elements that they're looking at in
there and then there is just this other
side of it which is you've got this sort
of fan base and it's a such a world that
people have invested in for such a long
time and so it's a privilege to be
Patrick personally who was what made you
come back to this personal the
intentions of creativity the writers and
the and my co-executive producers they
when I met with them it was to tell them
why I was going to turn the show down
because they had been so courteous and
polite and I wanted to make it clear
that it was nothing that I held against
the show but there were there were a
feeling that I it was in my past it was
over and I just wanted to keep moving
off and then I saw what they were
intending and planning and I saw that if
I did the show I would still be moving
on and that was too appealing for me to
turn it down so really is a different
chapter it really is oh yes know that it
is it's a completely sort of new
beginning in many in many ways but it
has that thing where it goes deep you
know any time and and everyone you
really get to meet everyone and it
delves into each character and it's just
incredible to work that we're so far in
as well we show seven by now we're in
half three to go and you know it's been
it's been just an incredible journey
okay I know you guys all have these
secrets but I mean you tell us one cool
new thing there were you know every time
Star Trek comes on new Star Trek comes
on there's something cool and new like
some gadget uniforms you know every
everybody is with blank
whiskas we're going in our minds can you
say I'd say there's probably a lot more
hand-held camera work than has ever been
we get blankets it's shot and thank you
for saving that question and so far
we've had four directors and two of them
are women that's right Wow on our first
one a woman coming and you look around
our crew and yeah it does it is starting
to extend you know Franken is in behind
ya know yeah so we will see you back
here next year don't cross your fingers
[Laughter]